the lady who just gave me my job has
just told me that she
delivered the 20 millionth vaccine so
that's really exciting
so i might be 20 millionth and one
for nicola this is a milestone worth
celebrating
she knows this is her ticket to freedom
she was among hundreds in coventry today
only too happy to wait their turn okay
20 million vaccines have unlocked the
future for millions
it's a step the medical and scientific
world have fought hard to achieve
this is absolutely light at the end of
the tunnel i'm feeling quite overwhelmed
actually because
every moment we hit a new incredible
target all i can think about
is the incredible amount of planning
that's gone into
reaching this moment um we could have
all the vaccine in the world but without
the incredible
uh staff and volunteers behind the
scenes and and in front of the scenes
we wouldn't have reached this mark so i
feel overwhelmed and very very proud as
well
but the smiles are short-lived as for
the first time
six cases of the brazilian variant of
concern
have been identified in england and
scotland
two in south gloucestershire three in
northeast scotland and one whose
location is unknown
all except one have links to
international travel to south america
i think the reason why this is such a
concern is that we are
we want to prevent the spread of this
new variant
in in and around the country uh the p1
variant which was first described in
manaus in brazil
has very similar mutations to what uh
is called b1351 which was first
described in south africa
we are concerned that this may have
increased transmissibility
may lead to more infections and we don't
yet know the vaccine effect
and so really want to prevent the spread
in the uk population
surge testing will begin tomorrow it's a
familiar pattern
the trio of testing tracing and
isolating to contain the spread
it proves how fast moving the pandemic
can be
the highs and lows we are still seeing
nearly a year on
ashnaharanag sky news